And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call, oops, that was my screen there.
Okay, welcome to another Zoom call.
We're going to get started with everybody's questions.
If you're new to the Zoom calls, remember a member site that you can go to the Zoom call section.
Actually, I think that's undisturbed.
Every page of the member site where you can ask your questions.
And remember, too, when you hit submit, the question that you typed in there doesn't go away.
So you're like, ah, document's not going away.
Did it not go through?
It does go through.
If you forget, if you hit submit or not, just hit it again.
So I get it twice or whatever.
It's no big deal.
But just so you know, you don't get anxiety that your question didn't get submitted.
I don't know why that feature is on.
I have no idea.
We have no control over that.
I apologize.
But just a quick note.
And then if you have questions, while we're doing the Zoom call, you can chat them in.
And we do ask that you keep your video off.
You will be entered in muted.
So if you do want to speak in a question, um, just wait until we get done with the questions that were submitted.
And then you can unmute yourself to remember.
Also at the room page of the member site, there are announcements.
There's no new announcements for today.
But I always check the home page of the member site.
Okay, so first question is I have a slight animation in my tumor marker test.
Is that a call for alarm?
It depends on what tumor marker we're talking about.
So let's say so PSA is a tumor marker for prostate cancer.
And if you still have your prostate and you have a slight elevation in your PSA.
No, that's not a call for alarm.
If you have had your prostate surgically removed and you have a slight elevation.
Then that is a call for alarm because your PSA if you've had your prostate removed should be really close to zero.
So usually it's measured as point five or something your PSA.
And if it jumped up to three, when you had surgical removal of your prostate, then that would be even though it's only a three point to a half point jump.
Good to say, that's nothing.
But it is if you don't have a prostate.
Any of the other tumor markers, the CA199, the CA1532729 common ones would not be a cause of alarm if there's a slight elevation.
Now it is good to look at any blood test over time.
You're looking at out of graph, if you're getting this slow elevation over the last three years, it's going, you know, in a upward direction on each test.
Of course, that you need to look at that as a cause of alarm.
Remember with any blood test, it's a clue of something that's going on.
You don't treat totally based upon a blood test.
It's certainly not based upon one blood test.
So if there is a giant jump in a, in any marker.
So this is not even just a tumor marker test, but if there's a giant jump in any of your markers, your alkaline phosphatase, your AST, or ALT, or your, a giant jump in white blood cell count, that's, you know, always an indication of something possibly going on.
So you want to take a closer look at that.
But if let's say you have a CA153, I think the normal is 0 to 35, and let's say it was 42, and then we did the test to get it, it was 48.
Is that a cause for alarm? No, but you would also look at the possibility to, you know, rerun that again and test it over time.
So any lab test that you're running, any marker that you're looking at is a clue to something going on.
So if you have an elevation or a drop in anything, you want to investigate possible reasons why.
And there could be a lot of, a lot of very done pathological reasons why things can change.
Next question, what I did my mycotox test.
It showed several elevated mycotoxins.
I've been following your protocol to help detox these and had my house checked.
When can I retest?
Okay, so typically I suggest if you have started a protocol of detoxification of these mycotoxins,
you've tested your home, you've done all the investigation, you possibly can.
If there was positive findings in your home, you started the remediation processes, et cetera.
Then I would say both six months post started all that.
So let's say, you know, we did the mycotoxin test to keep it simple January 1st.
And we didn't get started on remediation, either internal remediation,
meaning taking binders to pull that stuff out and key laders to pull those mycotoxins out.
And dealing with home issues, let's say you tested your home with your bathroom had mold,
and now you have a mold, mold remediation company coming in and cleaning up your bathroom.
That's not done till the end of February.
I would say six months after that.
Give yourself some time because if you're still exposed to mycotoxins through the end of that period of getting your house cleaned, not per se,
you know, nothing's going to really change even if you're doing a lot of chelation,
you're still going to have heretic exposure.
So I would wait typically about six months post starting all that therapy.
Consider it your creating your house is as a therapy as well.
What should I be taking to ameliorate the effects of radiation therapy?
I am undergoing for a non-small cell lung cancer.
I have your radiation, homeopathic dropper formula, but the bottle says it's for pet scans and CT scans.
So would the homeopath work for radiation therapy?
So you're doing radiation therapy through radiation oncologists.
They're radiating your lung in this case or whatever they're radiating.
Can you help mitigate some effects of the radiation by using the homeopath?
Yes, you can. I'd say yes. I would use it with me.
I would be using the homeopath for that as well.
The radiation homeopath that we have it's for pet scans and CT scans.
Meaning that it was just tried in that label we were trying to indicate to people that it's the pet scans and CT scans are where you're getting radiation.
So that's where we're trying to block that.
But certainly if you're doing radiation therapy, you could use that.
We also have another homeopath from PHP called Raydolin, Randalin, R-A-D-Y-L-I, something like that.
So that's another homeopath that's kind of multiple different radiation things.
Personally, if you're going to radiation therapy, I would do both of those.
So you can call Megan in the store to ask her about the Randalin drops.
I don't know if I could answer that right from PHP as well.
Next question. I have been taking Ivermectin and Vendezol.
Are they good for sensitizing the tumor cells during my 30-planned radiation sessions? This is the same person.
This would be a compliment to the weekly chemo session that I have been that they have been doing for this purpose.
Yes, you know, there's some talk out there on the internet that Ivermectin and Vendezol help increase the effective chemotherapy and or radiation and increase the benefit.
I don't know if that data how correct that data is.
So I can't really speak to that or not.
I can say that both Ivermectin and Vendezol are not counter active to radiation and or chemotherapy.
They're not they're not antioxidant therapies. They're they're not oxidative therapies either.
So they're not complimentary in the sense that they're increasing the oxidative stress that chemotherapy and radiation are producing.
That's how radiation works. That's how chemotherapy works is that it's creating a high degree of oxidative stress. That's what radiation does.
So radiation to a healthy cell could end up causing cancer because it's creating oxidative stress.
But to a cancer cell, it could cause cell death because a cancer cell is already has a higher level of resting oxidative stress near its lethal death limit.
So it's sitting at a state its resting state is nearer of the threshold of lethal death of oxidative stress.
So the radiation key and chemotherapy and almost every therapy that you're doing from my clinic is an oxidative therapy.
You're taking you know, protocell oxidative therapy. You're taking high dose curriculum and high dose vitamin E, high dose burmarine, high dose vitamin C.
All those are oxidative. So almost all the therapies that are done from a natural perspective to kill cancer cells are oxidative because cancer cells are already sitting at a higher oxidative stress level.
And we're just pushing them past that threshold of lethal death. That's how it works.
So, but I've been back to the fed Mendezole though there's been multiple pathways that have suggested it's metabolic benefit for cancer.
One of the key components that I believe is that it up regulates the intrinsic apoptonic pathway by up regulating the p53 tumor suppressor genes.
So remember your tumor suppressor genes kick on and kill cancer cells when it senses the cell going into rapid replication, quote unquote cancer.
So tumor suppressor genes will kick on and activate the intrinsic apoptonic pathway to kill a cancer cell.
I've erected and fed Mendezole help do that. That's one of the ways that curriculum and burmarine work as well. They up regulate the different tumor suppressor gene pathways.
So, it's not counter intuitive to say that could I take Iver back to the fed Mendezole while I'm doing radiation or while I'm doing chemo. Of course you can there's no there's no negatives of that.
The only caveat that I'd say is you have to make sure you're checking your liver markers because chemo is very toxic.
Whereas like taking high dose vitamin C or taking high dose curcumin or burberry or you know other things that I have you guys on is not as non toxic to healthy cells and it will almost never cause you know irritation in your liver.
You're elevating your AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase. It spares healthy cells. That's the benefit of a natural approach. That's a benefit of doing the right that spares healthy cells.
However, fed Mendezole and Iver back to our medicines so as chemotherapy is a medicine those are drugs they don't spare healthy cells and they can be toxic to your liver if you don't detoxify them well.
So you should be checking your liver markers and how you do that is getting a comprehensive metabolic panel.
So you can ask for a comprehensive metabolic panel. Typically if you're doing chemo they're doing blood every week.
They're doing blood every time I go and do chemo while they're only doing a CBC.
So they're only looking at your red blood cells and your white blood cells because chemo is also going to destroy your white blood cell line.
So that's the negative about doing chemo whereas most of the therapies that we're going to recommend don't do that.
Even Iver back to the Mendezole don't lower your white blood cell count.
But it can damage your liver marker. So when you go into chemo every two weeks or every week whatever you're doing and you're getting a blood test,
if they're not doing a comprehensive metabolic profile, they're not looking at your liver marker.
So you have to ask for that sometimes if you're doing the Mendezole and Iver back to you should be getting regular comprehensive metabolic profiles.
If you're doing any chemo or radiation you should do that too. Unfortunately a lot of oncologists go order them.
You're going to have to be wise enough to ask for those.
Next question. If toxins are a cause of my cancer how does that exactly happen?
I think you're asking how do toxins cause cancer?
Well remember anything that gets inside of a cell has the ability to damage cellular components.
It can damage your mitochondria, it can damage your lysosomes, it can damage any of your organelles can be damaged due to toxins or anything that gets inside of a cell.
If it damages the nucleus and causes it to go into rapid replication it is a cause of cancer.
You know what can be a cause of cancer? You know you hear read about things or used to back in the 80s and 90s all the time.
That barbecued food is a cause of cancer. This is a cause of cancer. This is a cause of cancer. This chemical is a cause of cancer.
And you go oh my gosh I can't do anything. The truth is anything that you don't detoxify, anything that you absorb that is circulating in your blood and you don't detoxify is going to be pushed to extra cellular spaces
and it eventually can be put into cells. If anything that gets inside of a cell has the potential of being a cause of cancer.
Not everything gets inside your cells but anything that does get inside a cell has the potential of causing cancer.
It's always something that gets inside of a cell. Could it be a bacteria? Yes. Could it be a virus? Yes. Could it be a toxin? Yes.
So bacteria and viruses are labeled biotoxins, they're living organisms and inert things are labeled toxins. So it could be a biotoxin or a toxin that gets inside of the cell.
Damages and nucleosid causes it to go into rapid replication. That's what happens. The truth is you could live to 120 years old, never get cancer.
We dissect your body and we see lots of cells that have toxins in them. It doesn't mean it's going to, it means it can. It has the ability to damage your nucleus and then cause cancer.
The truth is that everybody's getting cancer all the time, but you have healthy tumor suppressor genes, your tumor suppressor system kicks in, kills that cancer before it's 100 cells large.
It can't be seen on a CT scan MRI or PET scan until it's 3 million cells large. Oh, that's large. It's been going on for a long time.
Usually a cancer doesn't get identified diagnosed as a cancer until it's been growing for years. Now there has been evidence of what's called turbo cancers since the recent jam.
That is because the spike proteins can be a major cause of cancer and it causes cancer to grow quite quickly. That's what's been labeled as a turbo cancer.
We need somebody who gets diagnosed and they pass away within 3 months even before treatment can start because it's growing so quickly.
So the rate of cancer of that cellular replication is different with different cancers, is different with different people.
The purpose that you want to develop in the diagnosis of cancer is that you slow the rate of replication.
Everybody wants their cancer to go away. They want it to disappear. That's not always possible. You want it to stop growing. You want it to stop replicating. That's really what you have to do.
If it stops replicating, then it's technically really not a cancer. Yeah, but the mass is still here. I know, but it's not replicating anymore. So it's just a tumor now.
So the bulky that tumor might be a good thing to do might be a bad thing to do. You don't want to wake it up. So it depends on where it is if it's affecting other organs as well.
Okay, next question. Can I substitute Ben Ben pure for your Ben Ben Dazole safeguard if I use the same dosage?
The reason is I have two bottles left for the previous run at this and I would like to use them up. Absolutely. Yes. So if it's if it's just Ben Ben Dazole and you're using the same dosage. Yeah, absolutely. Yes, use those up for sure.
It makes no sense to have that go to waste. Is demulizing glutathione okay or a cancer patient? I heard you say it can be good for lung issues.
So when would somebody demulize glutathione?
So nebulized glutathione could be really good for the brain. It can be a good way to get glutathione in your system.
So years ago we used to see a lot of patients that had Lyme disease and a lot of patients with fibromyalgia and other autoimmune issues.
And we used to use nebulized glutathione in our office. Part of the reason why we use nebulized glutathione is that
there wasn't real, at that time there were algodethione was not on the market.
And liposomal gland is glutathione didn't exist as a supplement.
So glutathione is extremely poorly absorbed. Now there are all the glutathione on the market that's in a capsule form that's a powder is algodethione.
It's much better absorbed. The liposomal glutathione is even better absorbed.
So there really isn't a need to use nebulized glutathione.
Except if a person has lung issues, person has lung infections, lung disorder autoimmune attacks to their lung using nebulized glutathione could be extremely beneficial.
However, should a cancer patient ever use glutathione?
In general, no, they shouldn't. Remember, glutathione? Remember, I just said a few questions back that cancer cells are already at a higher resting state of oxidative stress.
Near the lethal dose crossover of oxidative stress where they could die.
So your therapies with cancer are oxidative to help push them past that lethal dose to help cancer cells die.
Glutathione is an antioxidant. It's the strongest cellular antioxidant.
So if you're going to take glutathione when you have cancer, you have the potential of keeping cancer cells alive.
So we don't want to do that unless it tests perfect for you, which is a few and far between not very many cancer patients have I use glutathione with.
So in general, I would say no, don't use glutathione.
But what if I have cancer, but now I have this lung infection that I'm dealing with?
Well, if you have a lung infection that you're dealing with, I wouldn't necessarily use glutathione anyhow.
It's a lung infection. You want to use something that's going to help kill the infection.
Nebulizing hydrogen peroxide, that's formula that's on the member site home page is the formula for it's the Mercola formula for how you have to water down the hydrogen peroxide to the right percentage.
Nebulizing hydrogen peroxide can be extremely beneficial for any lung infections.
It can also be beneficial for cancer patients. If you're really into nebulizing and you want to nebulize things, nebulizing hydrogen peroxide can be beneficial for cancers.
But certainly lung issues, it's going to be more beneficial for.
If you have lung infections, you could nebulize colloidal silver. There's other things you could nebulize as well.
And why would a person nebulize? Well, you're getting it right into the lung.
It's easier to cross the alveolar space, the lung barrier. So you have barriers. You have a gut barrier.
So if you have damage to your gut, a lot of supplements are food that you're eating, maybe you're not absorbing a high percentage, but you could absorb a lot through the barrier of your lung.
So it can increase the absorption rate by doing nebulized different things. However, you got to be careful if you're nebulizing it all the time.
You can be irritating your lungs too, so you got to be careful in that. So there's a balance there.
So in general, I would say no cancer patients should not be nebulizing glutathione. There's a good question.
Should everyone be doing coffee and it is well, it depends on what you mean by everybody.
If you meet every cancer patient, yeah, probably. Yes.
But I would say it partly depends on where you're at with your cancer. So I feel like I'm in full remission right now. I haven't done coffee enemas.
I think I did. I had a week of doing coffee enemas about six months ago. If I remember, so I was having some issues, but it's probably six months before that that I did them.
So I don't do weekly or daily coffee enemas anymore. But if you're in the throes of your cancer, do a daily coffee enemas, I'd say yes.
If you're in your throes of your cancer, you're having issues with detoxification, you're having issues with anxiety, you're having issues with your immune system, you're in your having issues with constipation, you could do multiple coffee enemas per day.
Backscarcer used to recommend people that are in later stage cancers that they're doing five coffee enemas a day. How can they possibly do five coffee enemas a day takes to takes me half an hour to do a coffee enemas.
Well, you go on our site and you do the easy peasy way to do a coffee enemas. So we talked about this last week or the week before to the easy peasy way of coffee doing coffee enemas.
They're going to definitely stimulate a person to do coffee enemas more often because it's super easy hence in the name. So you're just doing them in the shower standing. You're not rolling on your side and on your back making a mess worried about you're going to spill all over it.
Have to clean that up and do all it doing the easy peasy way of doing coffee enemas is just that easy peasy. Okay, question on the chat.
I had a call with you yesterday and I heard you tell me I should look into chemo to get my mass shrinkage started. Please confirm you think that might help me.
Or should we give the right for chance for a week by lymphoma mass is large.
Yeah, so the answer to that is always always going to be have to be your call. I can't legally tell a person not to go do a biopsy or to go do a biopsy.
I'm just going to give you an opinion. If there's going to be a process that has you have to go through you have to have it at a biopsy yet.
You're not going to just be able to go in and say, okay, I need to get started with chemo let's get started right away. It's going to be a process of we have to schedule the biopsy then we have to schedule the chemo it could be two weeks down the road before anything gets started.
So there can be a benefit to getting the biopsy now at least getting a schedule to get it probably won't get scheduled till next week.
And then once those results come back, which might be several days, then, you know, you could schedule the chemo, but you did it will give us some time in that to, you know, we'll be a week down the road before chemo would even be an option.
So getting started with getting a biopsy may be in order if your mass is large, the concern with having a large abdominal mass of any kind is that it could put pressure on other organs.
If it blocks your intestinal tract, then we're in trouble. You have an intestinal blockage. You can't just live with an intestinal blockage.
If it puts pressure on the pancreas and causes pancreatitis, that is a huge crisis.
Pancreatitis inflammation of the pancreas can cause an infection in the pancreas and that could be a number you don't want to, you don't want to find yourself in a position of an emergency.
So you're going to the ER and an emergency situation and they're having to do an emergency surgery.
If you can possibly plan ahead and getting some things done that would have to take place if you want to do the chemo.
And that would be in this case, getting a biopsy may be wise to get that scheduled so that if, you know, doing the right, doesn't make a big difference within the first couple of weeks and things are going the wrong direction.
You have the ability to go in and do chemo. Without the biopsy, you don't have the ability to get started with chemo until you jump through that hoop.
So if you could jump through that hoop so you're more prepared, should you want to do chemo that might be a good idea.
That's that's all I'm saying doesn't mean you have to go and schedule chemo right away, but at least you'd be prepared so that you're not in an emergency situation.
Next question. Could you name a specific supplement to increase NK cells, NK cells are natural killer cells. That's a some type of white blood cells.
So natural killer cells and T cells are the some types of white blood cells that are essential for killing cancer.
So there's labs that you can do that you can measure your natural killer cells and you can measure your T cell, you can measure your lymphatic subsite cells.
If you there's a Syrex, I think it's a rate 29 or something like that where it's a full panel or a measure in all your lymphocytes, sometimes.
Do I think that's necessary to do that? No, have I ordered that very often? No, unless somebody actually just is begging me to do that. Why?
Because there isn't like a magic thing you can do to to increase those things. There's no specific supplement that can increase those things.
Even though there are supplements out there in the market, I think biotics has a has an NK cell supplement. I don't know.
But I don't remember if it was biotics or a different supplement that had a supplement named after that, but what was in there was vitamin C.
And you don't want to take that lower dose of vitamin C as a cancer patient anyhow. So it's like no.
The other immune, the immune stimulants that you're doing, you're taking mushrooms. If you're, if you're taking mushrooms, if you're taking, you know, different immune stimulants for your cancer.
Let's say oregano and, and, and echinacea and Burberry and turquoise. Those things are, are helping with that anyhow. There isn't going to be a specific supplement that's going to stimulate T cells or natural killer cells.
But you can look at what is necessary for your body to make these subsets of natural killer cells and T cells.
And we've talked about this multiple times before is that these are these subsets of white blood cells are completely dependent upon protein consumption.
So protein consumption is super important to make white blood cells. That's why I rarely advocate for somebody who has cancer to be on a vegetarian or vegan diet.
Because a vegan vegetarian diet, it's going to be very difficult for you to get adequate protein consumption.
And, and I know there's people out there that may listen to this video and argue that well, we can, I could eat enough mama means in order to, you know, get X amount of grams approaching. Well, maybe you can, but it's going to be much more difficult for somebody who's dealing with the chronic disease to eat that amount of
vegetarian protein in order to get the grams of protein they need. And it is recommended that you get that you're eating upwards towards one gram per protein per pound of body weight.
So if you weigh 125 pounds, you're trying to get 125 grams of protein.
If you eat a chicken breast, you can get 45 grams of protein, but I don't know how you could do that, you know, it'll eat it without eating some meat.
So eating some meat can be beneficial for them.
Eating red meat can also be beneficial for cancer patients if they have anemia, which is another common issue with cancer patients, you, you know, your cancer can be growing.
It can gobble up red blood cells, it can be gobbling up iron and you could have low iron stores, you could have anemia issues, it's very common with cancer.
And, you know, you could take iron, but you could be feeding the cancer with iron, so taking ornamented with iron is the way to go, but eating some red meat can be beneficial.
And, and you developing white blood cells and developing red blood cells.
So, to answer your question, no, there's not a specific nutrient that's going to increase natural killer cells or tea cells.
Next question, how do you tell the difference between alkaline, phosphatase going up due to bone metastasis or from taking benvenazole or another drug?
Is there anything to take to help the liver regardless of cause?
So, yes, so remember a marker, a blood marker is a sign that's a clue to something.
So, if there was a drug that reduced alkaline phosphatase levels, would that be a good thing to take if my alkaline phosphatase levels are going up?
No, that wouldn't be a good, I don't know, that's what you're asking, but no, that would not be a good thing to take because we don't want an artificially lower marker level that's telling us something, it's trying to tell us something, we don't want to put a piece of tape over its mouth, but it's trying to tell us something.
So, how would you go through a process of differential diagnosis with somebody who has metastasis to bone, it is unfed metazole and they have elevated alkaline phosphatase?
Well, a couple of things, if my alkaline phosphatase is elevated, is my calcium also elevated, is my calcium moving in a direction of going up over time, along with my alkaline phosphatase.
The answer to that is yes, that it's more likely due to the metastasis of bone because in a river alkaline phosphatase will be elevated due to irritation in the liver, that couldn't be from a drug, right?
From fenmentazole, one drug could be from chemo therapy too, could be from other drugs, could be from Tylenol.
So, you could get an elevated alkaline phosphatase with that.
Many times with a drug, you'll also get an elevated AST and ALT, sometimes not, but that would be another clue.
But when you have metastasis to bone with bony destruction, alkaline phosphatase is in bone two, so it will spill alkaline phosphatase.
You'll get an elevated alkaline phosphatase with bony destruction, but with bony destruction that elevated alkaline phosphatase will more commonly be associated also with elevated calcium because you're going to get spillage of calcium from the bone into the blood.
So, you're going to have, with the differential diagnosis is, if I have elevated alkaline phosphatase and elevated calcium, it's more likely, nothing's going to be perfect, but it's more likely due to bony destruction.
If I have elevated alkaline phosphatase and speared calcium, I mean my calcium is actually going down, but I also have elevated AST and ALT that it's more likely due to irritation and liver from medication or whatever.
So, that's partly how you would look at it, but you'd also look at somejective things. Do I have more bone pain?
Okay, that could be a study that the elevated alkaline phosphatase is coming from my bone.
So, there's other things that you'd look at too, but that's the key component.
And then the last part of your question, is there anything you take to help the liver regardless of cause?
Well, you're helping support your clean out your liver. So, yes, milk thistle, pun 1, or pun 1 phase 2 product, or phase 2.5 and phase 3 product, their main purpose to help clean out the liver.
So, doing pastoral packs over the liver, doing coffee enemas, you know, doing more coffee enemas per day.
And again, remember, the purpose of coffee enemas is not because you're constipated. That's a side effect of helping with constipation, but it's to help stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system to help stimulate the flushing of your liver.
And remember, your look back at that detoxification, seven phases of detoxification, remember, you all have access to all our courses.
The seven phases of detoxification talk about, okay, here's a common scenario. I can't detoxify my liver markers or high.
You're going to look downstream from that. Do you have a blocked gall bladder, especially as a female? Very common. You have a sluggish blocked gall bladder. What's going to help with that?
Well, pastoral packs really good for that coffee enemas are really good for that. So, look downstream from where there's issues.
Next question. I've been getting over a sore throat, cold, and I have always had problems with earaches and drainage.
In the past, a heating pad was greatly helped with the drainage. Would you recommend a heating pad you sell in a store for this application?
Yes, those heat pads that we sell in the store, we have gifted them a Christmas to all our children. We have several of them.
We used them a lot, especially in the winter. We used them whatever my wife is prone to to lung issues from her childhood. She uses the heating pads a lot.
So, those ones we have in the store are our favorite ones. I think they're the best heating pads in any other questions.
Okay, well, we'll call it for tonight. Reminder to, we have several new people that go to the member site, use the member site. That's your link to get on this. That's your link to ask questions.
We want you to use your Zoom calls as much as possible. Always remember if you have questions between now and next Wednesday, look on our blog, look on our video site, go to our main website.
There's links to the blog, links to the video site, you can search our video site, you can search our blog on our website.
Pretty good chance. I've answered that question in the past, and there's a video about it, or there's a blog post about it. I'm not trying to dissuade you from asking questions, but I am trying to help you get your questions answered in the most timely manner.
Okay, no, we'll be praying for all of you. We cherish your prayers for us, and we'll talk again next week. Bye bye.